donc si vous voulez un moment donné il
faut bien comprendre ce qu'on est en
train de raconter dans cette histoire on
vous demande de vous lancer dans un
projet on vous le valide et ensuite on
vous dépouille au fur et à mesure de
l'avancement donc évidemment la
production ne peut pas suivre moi je me
lance jamais dans un projet qui consiste
à faire deux trois dixites par jour ça
n'a pas de sens et Twitter de façon
frénétique tous les spécialistes vous
lui diront ça n'a pas de sens c'est
quand on est dans un compte
institutionnel j'ai twitté pendant une
époque sur un compte Mon Compte
Personnel énormément mais sur mon compte
personnel sur un compte institutionnel
ensuite différemment forcément donc
la même chose on parle d'une on part
d'une feuille blanche
tout est à créer
un compte sur chaque réseau social et
donc si vous voulez à chaque fois avec
une matière assez
originale pour pouvoir attirer
l'attention
donc aujourd'hui si vous voulez bien sûr
que je ne suis pas content des résultats
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise que je suis satisfait de moi je
suis pas je suis pas content de moi je
regrette profondément et je ne ferai
plus jamais confiance aux institutions
je le dire qui m'engage qui m'engagerait
à aller dans un travail je ferai
confiance dans voilà des relations comme
ça mais jamais jamais plus je ne suivrai
des demandes d'un responsable politique
jamais plus plus personne sauf dans un
cadre comme celui-ci où je suis
contraint ne modifionnera plus jamais je
n'échangerai sur mes thématiques avec
aucun responsable politique parce que
j'ai perdu confiance totalement
totalement dans l'action publique où je
vois d'ailleurs les lâcheter ce
manifester par la suite il aurait fallu
que chacun assume ses responsabilités sa
petite part de responsabilité chacun a
sa petite part de responsabilité je l'ai
dit en début d'intervention il y a pas
de malversation financière dans cette
affaire il n'y en a pas il n'y avait pas
une volonté de malversation financière
mais il y a des erreurs successives
encore une fois ce n'est pas ici je le
dis donc voilà
il n'y en a pas eu de la part de
personnes bien sûr de moi-même mais je
m'engage j'ai compris pour les autres
voilà